[Musique]
mais merci beaucoup et celui alors là
gilles ça va être bientôt à vous mais
juste avant est ce qu'il ya une mélodie
dans le public est ce qu'il ya une
mélodie dans pluie guillaume rejoint de
mélodies bien toi et là là là on va
rigoler comment ça va mais le dit saint
barth je te fais un gros bisou merci
d'être là mélodies mélodies tu nous
envoyer une petite vidéo c'est parti
salut baba ses mélodies voilà j'ai
besoin de ton aide
il faut que je présente mon copain à mes
parents je suis grave stressé et j'ai
envie de le faire d'une façon originale
alors s'il te plaît ma ba aide-moi
bisous
violet la belle mélodie parce qu'elle
voulait présenter son copain ses parents
mais ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a fait
croire à ses parents que son futur mari
c'était jean-michel à la vache
il est arrivé à la maison avec toute la
lourdeur que vous connaissez et jean
michel mr a fait quoi à ta maman que
c'était ton futur mari ton papa était
complice ton mec aussi est arrivé après
parce que vous allez voir ce qui se
passe et forcément c'est une séquence
culte qui va arriver dans un instant
reste avec une certaine 8
il ya une famille qui est avec vous une
famille qui a vécu des moments
difficiles puisque cette dame qui est
formidable et d'un amour avec qui j'ai
pu converser un petit peu pendant la pub
vous êtes vous êtes très sympathique
merci gros bisous
vous avez cru un instant que jean michel
maire allait être votre jambe alors là
et c'est vrai que ça c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle de la terre donc ça c'est vrai
que ça n'a pas été facile comment vous
happe réagiriez-vous valérie benaïm si
j'avais une fille et qu'elle mène avec
jean-michel non mais vous comprenez
c'est pas possible à la ramasse les
comprend
on serait tétanisé d'avoir un gendre
comme jean-michel ma mère elle m'a dit
direct quand j'ai intégré démission elle
m'a dit tout sauf jean michel n'a pas
besoin d'être une pêche au sommet
[Applaudissements]
oui mais c'est intéressant ce qu'elle a
dit comme tout est possible a été votre
maman elle hemeryck vous finissiez avec
qui dans l'équipe franchement avec mois
d'avril avec cyril je pense avec jean
mik
ah oui quand même la lm noter l
évolution du décès il rassure ouais
c'est vrai il est rassurant oui eh bien
c'est 500 lux et le pakistan vais le
voir avec une autre 9
oui bah sa meuf elle le voit avec une
autre 9 le zizi sortez la personne veut
pas dire ça n'est pas moi ça m'a
finances jean-luc la 10ème franchement
j'aimerais tellement que ça se passe
comme ça mais sans doute moi c'est de
confiance aveugle dangereux alors dont
elle est la mort il m'a écouté mais mon
père aucun aucun aucun bas c'est normal
les papas ils volent jamais qu'on chope
moi je sais que moi j'ai une fille ma
fille elle restera toute sa vie
célibataire
j'aimerais pouvoir à vous être aurez
vous le père aulas du noir il va et à
mon avis qui laisse pas ses chaussures à
l'entrée
les rendre à votre fille ça dérange pas
pour gêner les marches à part belle à
des chaînes rouillées qualité rigolez
pas rigoler pas que l'âge bien qu'à
pourra avoir son premier petit ami un
mannequin belge des morts alors quand je
vois pas avant 40 ans danielle gonnin
avait dit en début de semaine que vos
favoris c'était jean michel mr ouai si
jean michel maire vient et vous dit que
à la une relation et bianca tous les
travailleurs quoi sera majeur avec une
victoire extrêmement avec une dot choses
en une boîte de vous non de vous plus à
oui c'est vrai que j'avais pas compris
oui franchement oui mais franchement
reçu mon nom alors je le prendrai bien
ou là puisque elle travailla longtemps
non je jupe est très juste le nez
dadonov rejoindre c'est maintenant je
prendrai très mal à dormir je serai pas
rassuré je ne serai pas rassuré michel m
après tout si elle aime dire messieurs
mais on ne sait pas naturel bien mais il
faudrait qu'ils soient sérieux puis lola
la joue ma fille je suis moins mourir à
l'âge où ma fille aura la radio
alors on arrête de parler d'
affabulations je suis là pour poser les
questions
merci en tout cas d'être avec nous et
bien vous vous avez vécu ça votre fille
est extrêmement charmante et regardez
comme les baptêmes et jean-michel je
sais qu'il aimait bien plus nos cousins
les datas je veux dire est ce que vous
êtes le vrai fiancée
là c'est le papa qui était complice là
c'est la maman qu'on appelait g et la
maman moi ce que j'aime c'est elle c'est
ken est vive à quoi ça aurait peut être
la maman d'enora oui eva rivas grave
regardez jean michel maire est allé
faire croire qu'il était le fiancé de
votre fille pourquoi ça partait d'un bon
sentiment parce que vous vouliez voir
les jantes et pour la première fois
votre fiancée avec vos parents et vous
ne saviez pas comment faire donc on a
trouvé ce petit ce petit scénario
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon si je vous ai fait venir ici tous
les deux aujourd'hui c'est parce que je
vous vous présenter mes nouveaux copains
d'accords et de l'installer en tout cas
tu veux quelque chose à boire tout c'est
lui bonjour ma chère maman qui
aujourd'hui bon bonjour jean michel je
n'ai pas trop fait sa santé non non
hermès c'est ça oui
j'en ai enchaîné c'est bon ça fait super
plaisir vous soyez mais quand je prends
les italiens c'est ça a complètement
vous en compte deux cents ans ensemble
je sais pas si vous me remettez un peu
quelque chose là parce que je fais un
peu de charme de télévision exactement
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est rencontré
avec mélodie c'est vrai plateau télé et
donc c est instantanée quoi je me suis
senti bien tu sais où sont les verts moi
j'adore litanie est néfaste à la pizza
et les femmes surtout ça y est je suis
sorti avec une tosca maman il ya
quelques années et des seins énormes
sublime nous les plus longue histoire
huit jours a valu jour plus je suis
toujours à jeudi mashaie reprenne
cherché mon téléphone je vais laisser
monter fortement la belge tant que telle
il faudra donc moi je prends un dossier
en tout cas sachez que moi votre fille
je suis vraiment je trouve vraiment
amoureux d'elle
pourtant j'en ai eu un j'aurais eu plus
de 1000 je pense
bon vous avez quand même une sacrée
réputation oui ça va ça passe 1 mais
votre fille franchement elle est dans le
top 10 ans si elle était un peu plus
coquines holly peut-être même dans le
top 5 serait
merci monsieur l'otan coup de téléphone
pour je peux m'absenter deux minutes
plaisir j'arrive de cetto il est pas un
peu space
non non c'est vraiment c'est un mec
sérieux mais par beaucoup de cul
comment savez vous avez quoi ben ari
minana rigole deux femmes dans la vie
nous ils août à dix mille espèces il ya
digne il c'est du sérieux
il n'a pas l'heur de plaire à toi maman
moi je le connais parce que je ne savais
pas l'émission et c'est vrai que c'est
un mec qui fait beaucoup la fête
bon après j'ai envie de te faire
confiance au mélo mais moi je vais te
mettre soutenir du jour n'est jamais une
relation difficile ne va pas te mettre
non plus avec quelqu'un qui est pas pour
toi quoi ça je vais là mais je sais que
tu sens bien alors je me suis mis à
l'aise en famille au matin
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop c'est trop ça vous fait
perdre la tête
c'est une blague quand tu trouves ça
normal
écoutez les origines mais j'étais bon
bout un gâteau qui met beau petit sa
dizaine de mois bah il est beau
évidemment qui est beau on regarde et
aux effets spéciaux pour moi je tenais
le pâtis sa copie je sais un petit boy
[Applaudissements]
ou sursis ou préfet n'aura pas eu trop
cher et bien c'est fait quoi
merci d'être là je suis pas superman il
est où le temps est un peu collant mais
je pense pas la pâte est acheté des
raisons tu aimes l'insee les parents de
l'ennemi eve lyne approchante et hermès
est en baisse à chanter ta mais mes
toiles semblent très proches encore peut
pas tout raconter quoi
moi je suis plus moi franchement j'ai
passé l'âge est jamais rompu sa revanche
contre j'ai tout essayé dans les vides
comme eto'o pour jaloux ça réussit
jamais libéré
la fois très bien ouais non moi je
préfère le terme libéré à libertines je
préfère une scission d'un coup libéré
tout cas combien il en reste deux
garçons devant nous et toi tu dis rien
tu trouves ça normal hormis tu peux pas
la laisser comme ça vous n'êtes jamais
content pour moi et que je suis tout à
fait d'accord mais le lourd mais le
couple classique c'est fini ça c'est
leur honneur 2010 est maintenant regarde
les oui oui je suis content je me dévoue
mais sérieux vous foutez de ma gueule
bah c'est pas parce que pour nous j'ai
eu la manière mais c'est la première
fois que vous nous voyez quand dès lors
quand c'est comme ça le talent et
surtout bien sûr michel valet non mais
là c'est une blague c'est pas possible
l ombre h laurent il ya cinq minutes
l'aller sur l'autre sinon même
franchement non mais tout est prêt à
accepter ça faut arrêter de déconner
loti lancé baroin
franchement mais le camp espagnol invité
ce soir tu te veulent trop gras d'oie et
des mamans de dons s'il était peu
importe qui les emmenait à oui si elles
sont rasés
attendez on perds et tu t'écrases depuis
tout à l'heure je trouve ça bien
arrêtez-vous m'agacer c'est bon c'est
bon j'ai plus envie de rigoler la mélo
tu peux t'asseoir convenablement steeple
site okajeux ses portes c'est pourquoi
la stata c'est trop pas encore l'âge que
je te met une paire de claques moi je
m'y arrête tu m'énerves toiles volées
c'est le ferry toi tu vois pas ce qu'il
est dangereux puisqu'il est un
appartement dans le xvième ça y est ça
t'intéresse et j'ai bossé pour la voir
je pose deux heures par jour
ouais en plus je veux dire pour se le
dise young people a attiré vote à
machemont dos et je pense que finalement
vous êtes pas encore plus con kanaté les
bons et vous savez quoi vous m'avez soul
et je me casse
papa et bein si je vais dans la ville
on l'a fait venir ce soir c'est pour une
annonce importante quand même j'habite
au milieu en fait voilà si je vous ai
fait venir aujourd'hui c'est que jean
michel c'est pas mon vrai copain et les
vrais copains c'est martin
[Applaudissements]
voilà bah oui c'est pas moi mon sens
avec mois d'affilée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dur est à venir car efforts de johnny
c'est sûr
c'est évident elle est formidable
et puis évident je vous met autour de la
table un jour avec soin franchement vous
mettre autour d'agapes si jamais vous
êtes formidable c'est le papa qu'est ce
qui laissa ouais bah damour et venez
vous n'avez pas eu peur que ça parte un
petit peu en cacahuète non non en fait
c'était c'était pour le remercier de
m'avoir qu'ils étaient il ya vingt deux
ans un coup de pot à seebach et merci on
vous avait dit que c'était que de la
bourse
mais alors je sais que tu es un peu
jaloux et mine de rien quand italie la
terreur sur les fesses et ait un peu
énervé j'ai fait cligner des yeux un
petit peu forcément anormal
il y avait quand même un risque donc bon
non me stresser vous préférez moi je le
trouve très bien mais c'est justement ça
lui donne encore plus de valeur à
l'argus balle un crime
merci rendez-vous alors et mélodie elle
a été formidable
mélodie est ce que vous avez un petit
peu stressé parce qu'un moment votre
maman franchement moi quand elle a
commencé à fracasser
je me suis dit ça va partir très loin
vous avez un peu stressé ou parce que
j'ai stressé à grave
oui elle elle est nerveuse maman vit l
énergie mais bon et vous êtes en mai
mais vous êtes un personnage
exceptionnel
j'aimerais juste revoir au renvoi de
petites choses parce que j'aimerais
qu'on voit quand même l'autre région
michel aux flics parce que ça ça restera
dans les annales à regarder nos b
regardez je suis à l'aise en famille
le mec
et le regard et à notre petit je pense
que vous avez envie de revoir c'est le
voir l'adresse je suppose qu'on peut
acheter ce à l'adresse ci vous est-ce
qu'on peut acheter ça ces petits gâteaux
les bulles circoncis ou bas il est beau
évidemment qu'ils avaient beau regard
des effets spéciaux pour moi je tenais
le petit sac hôtel je sais un petit bout
de couilles ou non mais je voulais vous
remercier et je voulais vous dire que
tous les deux vous savez vous allez vous
peut-être vous marier bientôt tout ça
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que vous allez partir tous les deux à
bali je vous offre
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci et bon pour vous et
pour vous alors pour hermès et pour
evelyne et bien les chéris vous aurez
une soirée dans un yacht gastronomique
alors prié l'ensemble pour y aller c'est
pareil d'accord après quelques fia mais
c'est bien c'est pas moi mais voilà je
crois que c'est mon papa qui vous soigne
oui oui eh ben vous êtes en bonne santé
merci de couronnes 2,8 depuis qu'ils
savent c'est la soirée de la mort on se
calme et série kevin des candidates
merci merci merci le soleil je vous
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur à tous les
deux si c'est bien value
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup ce soir si vous
nous rejoignez on est sûr c'est vite en
direct c'est dingue quand soirée va pas
longtemps fait votre vidéo aller j'irai
voter